هذه هي قصة أحد
أشهر نوادي الجولف في العالم ،
وهو أحد النوادي الغارقة في التاريخ ، لكنه كان نادًا
شعر الكثيرون
بالحاجة إلى التحديث والتحديث بينما
أراد الآخرون أن يظل كما هو
تمامًا ،
إنها قصة عالم صيني جديد
لقاء الاستثمار مع الحساسيات الإنجليزية التقليدية ،
هذه هي قصة نادي goworth للجولف الذي
ترسخ فيه عدد قليل من الأندية في
تاريخ الجولف الإنجليزي حيث
تأسست goworth في عام 1922 ،
حيث كانت سباقة إلى كأس ريدر في
عام 1926.
ومن عام 1964 إلى عام
2007 ، نظمت مباراة العالم.  الحدث
الذي شهد حضور العظماء في اللعبة
سنويًا إلى goworth
[موسيقى
] ، كما بدأت أيضًا في استضافة
الحدث الرئيسي للجولة الأوروبية
بطولة pga في عام
1984 وكان المقر الرئيسي
للجولة الأوروبية
منذ عام 1981.
موقعها في اللعبة ناهيك
عن  يعني الموقع داخل ملكية خاصة تبلغ مساحتها 700
هكتار في
ساري أن هذا النادي الحصري قد
جذب دائمًا النخبة المزعومة في المجتمع
[الموسيقى]
ولكن بعد أربع سنوات  عندما قامت شركة آسيوية
تسمى
Rainwood برئاسة أحد أغنى الرجال في
الصين chiang chai rui rungwang
بشراء goworth ، بدأت
تتصدر عناوين الأخبار لأسباب مختلفة جدًا ،
حدث نزاع مرير
بين المالكين الجدد
ومجموعة من الأعضاء عندما
تضاعفت رسوم العضوية السنوية  إلى مبلغ ستة عشر
ألف جنيه إسترليني ، تم
طلب رسوم سندات إضافية بقيمة
مائة ألف جنيه أيضًا
ولكن تم التنازل عنها في النهاية للأعضاء الحاليين
ستيفن مدى ضخامة المشروع خلال ثمانية
أشهر من حياتي
هو أفضل طريقة لوصفه أنه كان
مشروعًا ضخمًا
بشكل عام  ما هو رقم الاستثمار الذي
يدور حاليًا
حول الشمال 30 ، واو أنت تتعامل مع
كل سنت يخرج
لكتابة الكثير من الشيكات في الوقت الحالي ،
ولكن
الأمر يستحق العناء وماذا عن
الدعاية السلبية لأنها
تسربت من بعض الأعضاء  كانوا ساخطين
لأنه لم يكن النادي الذي
انضموا إليه في الأصل ، فالكثير منهم دفعوا الكثير من المال
للانضمام هنا لأنه  هذا
المكان الأيقوني وهو يأتي بسعر ولكن بعد ذلك
بدأ السعر في الارتفاع إلى حد
ما ، أليس
كذلك؟ لقد ارتفع السعر في عام 2016.
إذا كنا سننقل بالنادي إلى
المكان الذي أرادته الجولة الأوروبية
حقًا  كن مشتركًا في ملعب الجولف على
وجه الخصوص ، كان علينا الاستثمار بكثافة
وكان الأعضاء مستعدون للرحلة
معنا ، وقد ساعد ارتفاع رسوم العضوية
في تمويل استثمار بقيمة 30 مليون جنيه إسترليني
داخليًا وخارجيًا تم إنفاق حوالي ستة ملايين جنيه إسترليني
على ملعب ويست الشهير
حيث تُلعب بطولة pga
بما في ذلك تقنية sub-air التي
تضمن تشغيل الخضر
بثبات وسرعة على مدار العام ،
فقد كان الهواء الفرعي هو مغير اللعبة على ما
أعتقد إذا سألت فريقنا الأخضر عن مدى
إدارتهم للخضر الآن والسرعة و
صلابة الخضر هذا الأسبوع
لم نكن قادرين على القيام بذلك قبل
أن يتم الإبلاغ عن ذلك جيدًا قبل بضع سنوات ،
لم يكن بعض اللاعبين يأتون إلى هنا
لأن العشب القديم الذي كان لدينا
البوي كان مزهرًا عندما تشارك  أنا هنا
في مايو المكان يبدو جميلاً ،
الرودوديندرون خرجت
لكن الزهرة في العشب الآن
ليس لدينا هذه المشكلة